In problem solving,
when we're working
with problems with potential
and kinetic energy,
remember we have
our main concept
that the non-conservative
work causes
potential energy and
kinetic energy to change.
K final minus K initial plus
U final minus U initial.
Now, how are we going to
apply this in problem solving?
Well, what we'd
like to introduce
is a tool, which we're going
to refer to as our energy state
diagrams.
So the way this works is-- let's
have an example to think about.
Suppose you have a dome.
So here's some dome.
We can think of this
as the MIT Dome.
And you have an object
that is initially
at the top of the dome.
And then this object is
sliding down the dome
and at a later time it's at a
point somewhere along the dome.
Now eventually it's going
to fall off the dome,
but that's a separate question.
So how can we use
our energy ideas
to analyze this situation?
And the way we do
it is that we choose
first initial and final
states that we're considering.
Because our first
idea in the energy
diagram is to compare the
change in kinetic energy
between the initial and
change of potential energy
between the initial
and the final states.
So in our dome problem, we
would choose our initial state.
Let's draw our
object at the top.
And in our final
state, separately,
let's draw the object over here.
And then we want to
parametrize these states
by some type of
coordinate system.
So here we're going to have
some type of coordinate system
that we use for both.
Energy is a scalar, so we
don't have to worry about it.
And what I'll do is I'll
define an angle theta final.
Here from the vertical,
here theta initial is 0.
And I've now parametrized
my initial and final states.
Now, the important thing that
we'll do in the energy diagram
is to choose our 0
potential energy.
Where are we going
to choose this?
So we could say either
a surface-- we'll
call that potential energy.
And in this diagram,
I can choose my 0
for potential energy
anywhere I want.
But I want to draw it on my
initial and my final states.
So I'm going to
choose it right here,
and I'll denote
this as u equals 0.
And now I can now make a
list-- so I want to identify.
So step three is to identify
the K and U for each state.
So here we have K
initial, it's at rest 0.
And U initial, well, I
didn't introduce a parameter
R. U initialize is how high the
gravitational potential energy.
So in this particular
case, Mg times R.
Now over here, K final,
is 1/2 M V final squared.
And U final, we can denote
it here if I plot this out--
and that's R. And then
you can see that this
is R cosine theta final.
So that's MgR
cosine theta final.
Now, the fourth step is to
identify W non-conservative.
Is there any
non-conservative work?
Now, here let's assume
the dome is frictionless.
And that means that W
non-conservative is 0.
And our last step 5 is
we can apply the energy
principle, which is
W non-conservative
equals delta K-- let's write
out everything explicit
now that we've defined K
final-- minus K initial plus U
final minus U initial.
And you see the power of these
diagrams and this methodology
is we've now defined very
explicitly every single term
that appears in the
energy principle.
And so we can write out
our result that 0 K final,
1/2 M V final squared,
K initial, 0 plus U
final, MgR cosine theta final,
minus U initial, MgR, and there
we have applied the
energy principle
using the tool of
energy diagrams.